and that's what you want from people
that you surround yourself with whenever
you
degenerate in any of the multiple ways
that you're likely to degenerate they're
going to like whack you on the back of
the head and say you know clue the hell
in you know you're you're demeaning
yourself you're less than you could be
with friends it's the same thing they're
not friends if they're not these people
you want friends who when something good
happens to you they're happy about that
they're not like all bitter and
resentful underground and like saying
horrible things behind your back and
telling you how they did something that
was better and trying to drag you down
it's like that's not helpful and then
when something bad happens to you and
you go to them and you say look this
terrible thing happened to me first of
all they don't try to top it with some
like horrible thing that happened to
them because they don't have the
patience to listen and take a look at
the people that are around you and if
they're
not on the side of what's good for you
then
walk away